let's jump to this uh this story right
here we got from the new york times
democrats risky bat aid gop extremists
in spring hoping to beat them in the
fall
so this story is coming back because
some of the primaries are happening
today and we're gonna get the results as
to what happens however we're not going
to know if democrats nuked themselves
until the midterms but
if you're wondering why it is partly
that so many democrats are joining the
republican party and why republicans are
polling so well it's because democrats
have been directly funding
the messaging and and
pr support of
trump supporting candidates
they believe
like biden comes out and he's like ultra
maga and all the trump supporters start
laughing and everyone jokes about ultra
maga
they believe that moderates don't like
maga and don't like trump
so they're they're actually dumping
millions of dollars into republicans
because they believe that when the
republican wins they can beat them in
the general what they don't understand
is two things one there's no such thing
as bad press
dumping tens of millions of dollars into
a trump supporting candidate just makes
them more prominent permanently yeah and
two people are voting against democrats
they'll vote for a ham sandwich at this
point because gas is so high also this
literally happened right hillary
clinton's campaign wanted to promote
donald trump so they could run against
him because he thought he'd be easier to
beat the pied piper yeah they call him
the pied piper candice see that's why we
saw in the emails where they actually
focused on ben carson first and they
wanted to elevate donald trump yeah and
and try to take him out there and they
thought trump couldn't win so if they
promoted him and the the reason they
called him a pied piper was they thought
that if they got trump more prominence
it would force the other republicans to
adopt trump's positions so that trump
would guide the republican party in a
direction that would lose votes and then
trump won
and now they're all coming together and
they're and they're like remember the
thing we tried in 2016 that didn't work
let's do it again they're like i know i
know how we'll get an extremist
candidate that the american people will
hate he should be against grooming he
should be against grooming he should say
that it's bad and he should think that
abortion at nine months is also a bad
thing and then he'll lose because
everyone knows americans are all in
favor of that why well as you know from
the guardian eighty percent of people
support that which they don't but that's
what democrats actually believe they're
like look everyone i talked to at whole
foods agrees with me yeah no at around
heroin yeah you know heroin that's like
the even fancier one right right right
now in los angeles yes yes
so the democrats right now on january on
the january 6 committee are like this
country is in grave danger the far right
seeks to destroy our democracy and we're
funding them and promoting their message
and helping them build a base yeah so is
this uh is this perhaps a symptom of
being so tightly in your own tight
little uh echo chamber that you can't
see the way out yes possibly they live
in a bubble world it's a cult yeah and
they're like
if if we promote these people who
believe fringe things we'll certainly
win and then it's like what does the
candidate believe one candidate was like
i'm pro-life and they're like
promote him he's far right and then
you're like dude the guy who says
pro-life isn't going to constituents and
screaming like that all women should be
locked in prisons he's saying things
like
well you know i just think there's
challenges here uh particularly as the
democrats are pushing for abortion to
nine months and they go like wait what
and he's like yeah and they're like i
saw your ad on tv and he's like yes that
was paid for by democrats i'm like i'm
gonna vote for this guy so they're
watching too many movies they're
watching too much handmade uh tail
they're watching their own movies
exactly
that's literally part of the bubble and
what is it that the new york times is
calling it extremists because i'm pretty
sure they think margery taylor green is
an extremist and she won handily i
believe right they're they're watching
like the handmaid's tale yeah and then
sitting there going like i want to make
a show like this and they make like the
handmaid's tale two and it's even
crazier and then some other person
watches that and goes i want to make a
movie like this they keep one upping
exactly
ideology well this is what's hilarious
to me so many left-wing people on
twitter and even on like instagram
facebook other social media
you know outlets where you actually
interact with people you know so many
people i've seen will post things like
this is just like the handmaid's tale as
if they're making some like interesting
connection it's like okay
handmaid's tal was written by a
left-wing feminist
to critique how she thought our society
operates and oh my goodness left-wing
feminists think that that's how our
society operates like you haven't
observed anything she she made a book
about how she thought the world is and
then people who agree with her were like
yeah this book is kind of how the world
is
it's the craziest thing is
we talk about these these dystopian
novels 1984 brave new world fair
fahrenheit 451 even handmaid's tale and
it's not any one of them
someone back in the day they sit back
george orwell he's like i imagine a
future of a government that controls
everybody and force them to do these
things and then you have brave new world
where it's like people are controlled
through pleasure and medication and it's
like actually it's just all of it dude
it's all of it luke luke rokowski has
the shirt where it shows it's the wheel
it's the venn diagram of all the
different novels and it says you are
here and it's like in between all of
them logan's run and all that stuff
actually logan's wrong now that i think
about it also you i just want to mention
you guys are actually wrong so george
orwell
wrote a handmaid's towel but he knew we
weren't ready for it
so
he he passed it on and as well until
someone gave it to margaret atwood and
she said it's time but your kids are
going to love it yeah he was actually
writing about i think what uh he was
writing
george orwell was writing specifically
about uh
something like the spanish civil war and
stuff wasn't he interesting no no maybe
i'm wrong i'm confusing him i heard that
he had us an anti-socialism conversion
at the end of his life like constantine
um
and 84 is something i always i
i you don't want to get cliche but it's
good to look at it because 84 is a
really great way of looking at the
management of information obviously
media the the the the the snipping and
tucking and nipping and talking of
history so that people are have nothing
to really to go back no perspective
but brave new world i think is so so
pronounced in what we're going through
right now the genetic stuff um the the
sexualizing of children the
making
family
and obscenity i mean brave new world is
i think it's incredible and this is why
a lot of people don't want to vote for
democrats two reasons one the first the
most obvious is the economy stupid
gas prices this high
most people probably don't know anything
about politics
that's probably why they voted for biden
and that's probably why none they're now
like i think i'll vote for the other guy
because this happens
every time there's a there's a large
group of people that it's like i'm
jumping [ __ ]
a million democrats switched parties to
the republicans in the past year
from uh in 2016 it was nine million
obama voters i believe it was nine
million right nine million people who
voted for obama in the prior election
voted for trump yeah that sounds right
so you now have people today
looking at the democratic party
and just saying no
we talked about this the other day with
the lgbt pride events where you have
naked men you have there was a video
that was like it made me it really did
make me want to like just just flip the
table over and just like scream and wig
out
it's an old man in tighty whities
twerking in front of a little girl and a
woman walks up to little girl and makes
her wave to the man a couple times and
i'm just like what they're doing to kids
the things they're doing in the streets
uh who was it someone said make that
your campaign video
oh yeah i said that it's like that every
republican should just make that their
campaign video make that stuff because
they're the the democrats are not
condemning it i got an idea
i'm gonna take that video
and i'm gonna run it as an ad on google
and let's see if they reject a man
marching in a pride event don't they
think love is love yeah it'll be and
then and then if they reject it i will
i'm not even kidding i'll do this
literally after the show i'll put it
right i'll go into google and i'll say
here's the video i want to promote
and then we'll see what google says
about it no no you can't do that that's
wrong i'd like it's just an lgbt pride
event publicly with children around
there's a kid in the video what's your
problem it's safe for kids right let's
see you say it google i will put money
behind that and see if you allow it
uh hey i i get a lot of that we talk a
lot um i've had a few people try to try
to
try to reason with me about why you know
rainbow flagged this pride month that
like i i have not none of it anymore i
have nothing but disdain for the uh the
flag that i see popping up all over the
place nothing but disdain for it first
of all it doesn't represent gay people
nothing it refers it's the it's the
sigil
of a militant political movement and it
has it i i'm just i'm sick i got a
better idea amen let's put it up on a
billboard on times square oh my goodness
and every agency will reject it they'll
say no and i'll say this happened
publicly in front of children and i want
your company to write a letter saying
exactly why you will not allow a video
from an lgbt pride event in minnesota to
be played on a billboard there's no
political statement
there's no politic do you oppose pride
and they'll say no but this guy's like
well this was publicly available for
children so what's wrong
i'll send it to our empire right now
no no corporation wants to tie into that
that's more of like so this is the point
it's a free speech thing the point is
the corporations either have to publicly
state my company will not allow this ad
and that's all i want to hear i want
these big media buyers these massive
media advertising agencies to send the
email saying your ad has been rejected
and then i'll say these companies oppose
pride
right because the other thing you say
even if they said well you know this
doesn't is not representative of the
entire parade or the entire event it was
just one person okay then why wasn't
that one person arrested on no no the
little girls the people are cheering for
the guy yeah they're waving and they're
clapping and cheering i know they didn't
say get out of here they didn't you know
the little girl from the event the woman
walks with a little girl and she's like
wave and the little girl waves to the
man and then he waves back
so if that is okay and acceptable then
it should be up on i will i will put it
on the biggest billboard in times square
well i'll try to
let's see what they say yeah it's 125
000 for one month
it is
an insanely massive billboard yeah so we
actually we actually were trying to get
it and they don't they didn't allow
politics you go in for a month you try
to go in for a month oh yeah yeah yeah
and then and then what it'll be is we'll
so
if i if you if you do anything political
they reject you is pride political
that
i would they already know i don't think
they are they already have pride
billboards up in times square they do oh
absolutely that's like the main thing
they have up in times square in fact on
one of the digital billboards we have is
a matriarchy you know that's right you
know queer you know a billboard and then
on the uh on the on there's there's a
big tower it's like this massive really
long tall one it's got a bunch of things
that pop up saying diversity and
inclusion they pop up so could you take
this video and just overlay it with the
word pride
how would that pan out what would what
would they say if they were to reject
that what i'm going to do is i'm going
to email them and say hey i really want
to promote a video of a pride event
would you would that be cool is that
okay and they'll say of course it is and
then i'll send the video and see how
they respond and they'll be like uh i
don't know about that one yeah and it
should be nothing but like celebratory
editing
i'm not gonna edit it i'm just gonna
take the twitter video and be like here
you go yeah well well i gotta figure out
who i wanna layer in some confetti or
something like that you know they might
do they might be like on copyright
grounds we can't allow it
yeah if you don't get out right easy out
so we'll have to find one of these how
about the guy with the bugs bunny mask
oh
yeah that's disgusting holy cow
disgusting i mean i'll tell you this
the billboards that we do have do allow
politics so i wonder if you could just
like take the video of the old man
twerking in front of the little girl as
she waves and then a big thing saying
vote repub like vote republican or i
mean honestly for democrat
because he will be like i don't want to
vote for that i'll vote for a democrat
is a vote for this yeah there you go i
keep thinking vote for acceptance
this is this because it's true they say
acceptance it's like acceptance of what
what are you trying to get us to accept
let's say it let's say it let's be real
we know for a fact google will never
allow the ad we know facebook will never
allow the ad and we know not a single ad
buyer would allow me to show a a
publicly available video from a pride
event in minnesota they will outright
say no to it yet they will allow
children to watch it in the streets with
with no police intervention with no one
at the event complaining
so what what this is it's just it's so
it's so silly this is why nobody this is
why people are checked out man that's
why they're not voting for democrats
it's why they're just checked out all
together all together and when it come
and i i said it before there too we
really are at this age of where it's
it's like the end of the it's the end of
the politician we're getting to purely
sectarian ground right now there's
there's really nothing if politics was
easy
when easier when you have two people who
are kind of tethered to to similar uh
foundational issues speech you know uh
kitchen table economics you don't want
to spend more than you're taking in
things like that and in in the in the
scrum you can advocate for one thing or
another and make your best um make your
best pitch for the the the country at
large but we are so uh you were saying
it before taking little things like the
handmaidens tale or any other story
where you you presented to somebody you
share a meme how many times have you
shared a meme or something or a quote
from somebody you thought that was
really profound and then as soon as you
shared it you're like
this person is going to think this means
this for them and you you realize that
we're we're not seeing the same thing
anymore of course that's sectarianism
that we're we're budding i got i've got
a meme that uh uh that i saw schumann
had posted it i i then you know reposted
it because that's how memes go
and uh instagram doesn't want me to open
it all right let me see if i can get
this open so uh it says
you can throw the switch at any time but
then you won't be able to use the threat
of the trolley to fundraise anymore oh
it's the trolley problem where one track
has no people on it and one track has
five people on it and that's the joke
and then the funny thing is for the
people who actually follow this show
they know it's both like i think people
realize that both the democrats and the
republicans often play this game but i
see republicans post to this and they're
like it's exactly what republicans do
then i see the democrats posting like
it's exactly what the democrats are
doing and i'm like bro they're both
doing it
it's all of them there are some good
republicans there's
but the majority of the political space
is just bad yeah thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you